[Música]
llegamos directo a Lima porque fue
retirado El sexto ministro del interior
del gobierno del presidente Pedro
Castillo mientras algunos congresistas
dicen que también van a promover un
nuevo proceso de vacancia contra el
mandatario saludamos entonces a nuestro
corresponsal Francisco Zacarías
Francisco los saludo muy buena mañana de
miércoles que es lo último en esta
atención dentro del gobierno peruano y
que dijo el habrá exministro del
interior tras su salida de este gobierno
Francisco
Buenos días Mariano González saliente de
ministro del interior este gobierno
habría creado un grupo especial de la
policía para ayudar a la fiscalía en la
captura de ex funcionarios y los
sobrinos del presidente Pedro Castillo
Quiénes se encuentran prófugos de la
justicia esto motivó a Castillo a
remover lo del cargo ante esta situación
Mariano González señaló que no tiene
duda que Pedro Castillo a su parecer
tiene un compromiso con la corrupción y
señaló que todo esto habría generado su
retiro del Ministerio de interior para
obstaculizar a la justicia esto ha
abierto un nuevo capítulo en la
crisis que enfrenta El Perú y Mariano
González ha sido muy enfático al señalar
que Pedro Castillo no debe permanecer un
minuto más en el cargo esto ha motivado
que muchos congresistas
anuncien que van a preparar una nuevo
proceso de vacancia constitucional
contra el Pedro Castillo Francisco
también continúa el paro de
transportistas le pregunto Cuáles son
los sus pedidos porque ellos o pues
continúan paralizando sus labores
en realidad son ocho regiones del Perú
que están paralizadas los transportistas
obstaculizan las vías terrestres Ellos
están exigiendo que se elimine el
impuesto selectivo al consumo así como
también se frene el alza de los
combustibles Ellos están bloqueando las
vías pero no son los únicos también son
los agricultores quienes están
paralizando en las protestas piden que
se compre fertilizantes y que se otorgue
créditos y apoyo técnico al sector
Agrario el gobierno está contemplando
una misión
multisectorial para tratar de frenar
estos conflictos sociales que en su
segundo día de jornada han dejado al
menos cinco heridos el por otro lado el
gobierno alista un decreto supremo para
otorgar un dispositivo de ayuda a los
transportistas a través de un Bono
especial que le signifique la devolución
del 30% de lo que ellos gastan en los
peajes vamos a ver cómo evoluciona esta
situación la cual estaremos atentos Así
es Francisco Muy atento Entonces a lo
que ocurra en Perú por un lado Pues esta
crisis de política nuevamente dentro del
gobierno del presidente Pedro Castillo
con el ministro del interior y también
por supuesto este parabel que estábamos
hablando finalmente transportistas en
todo el Perú